okay I'm back this is not going to be a
long stream hopefully but I wanted to
stream one last time last few hours that
I'm in Malaysia
I'm flying to Singapore in just over 12
hours and I'll be flying to Australia in
about 24 hours so let's do some puzzles
and then I'll probably play so if
there's anyone watching right now and
you want to play me feel free to send me
a challenge do a mix of puzzling and
playing so this is reconfigure the
windows here see the chat okay this is
black to move
blocks down upon but there's a number of
things jumping out I mean II four is a
fork there's also a pin on the B file B
three looks like a free pawn now B 3 we
tray the bunch like rook takes b3 rook
takes b3 rook takes me three Queen d2
well I guess there's rook be won in the
end
but if or also looks good like do I
choose ice cream or the cake that's is
too tasty looking options here so I
should probably find a reason to reject
one of the moves
maybe e4 Bishop takes e4 pawn takes e4
rook d5 there's some compensation
good morning to cycle rooks except it's
the evening here it's 8:55 p.m. that
good morning to wherever you are an
extra Mendota hello and go Ovid on a you
are not first you are seconds so I'm
really conflicted here because or maybe
rook takes b3 roof takes b3 rook takes
be three there's Queen c2 but then I can
take in e4 in the end
there's only one answer this is this is
frustrating rook takes b3 row takes be a
rook takes b3 Queen
oh maybe Queen takes b3 takes takes and
then white has cop
rook b7 and then blocks better but okay
I think I'm gonna go for efore cuz I
don't see anything wrong with efore it's
just a fork and there's still all this
pressure on the B file hold my breath
yes Queen f6 probably Bishop g7
I don't see anything immediately wrong
with taking the rook though if I take
the rook coin off seven then Bishop g7
I could take the Knights - there's so
many enticing options have the cake have
the ice-cream have the candy
I mean Bishop g7 just doesn't move that
I would probably play in a game I kicked
the Queen when the rook
a g5 doesn't do anything I don't think
actually maybe I'm Bishop g7 Queen h4 I
take the rook Knight g5 that could be
annoying actually so I have to be a
little bit careful like Bishop g7 Queen
h4 I take the Knights maybe I should
just take the rook first it's a weird
problem
it seems like there's multiple ways yet
advantage
I'm leaning towards taking the rook
ah but should have sevens of threats
chef sevans a monster threat okay so if
you take the rook Bishop f7 maybe I can
resign I feel like if this were a game I
could very easily let my guard down and
just take the rook and allow Bishop f7
so okay Bishop g7 Queen h4 and then I
take the Knights probably if I'm up a
piece okay I can live with that Knight
g5 first I have to take take Queen will
take
if I play King h8 night f7 is subpoena
hmm if Queen takes there's still this
threat of some like perpetual but it's
probably easy to stop like Queens u7 or
something and blocks up the pieces ok
hello to more people in the chat hello -
Lucy moody with the emotes psycho rooks
Malaysia is good Malaysia was a bit
rainy today I got wet many times so I
stayed inside most of the day
took a nap woke up really early to teach
but it was good good morning - toilet
not again what time is it
I guess it's 7 a.m. in the u.s. Lee
central time so it's not too bad our
Gila is says 3rd I don't think you were
3rd you're like 7th or something
Joker Sun my tactics rating is is 2505 I
gained 4 points from that puzzle people
saying take rook taking rook would have
been really bad
hello - sentai sentinel returns and Kate
2345 ok we'll do one more puzzle and
then we'll play some people bruno rola
welcome back
ok so this is back to move a first thing
that comes to mind is just taking the
rook and Bishop h4
the equal material this rook is trapped
kind of Ciroc take c1 if Queen takes we
win the bishop if rook takes Bishop h4
queen III Bishop takes a 1 and then
Bishop takes a fates
there's Bishop h4 immediately - hmm
there's Bishop d4 immediately
you take sticks
Bishop H for Queen III weights no if
Queen III I just take the bishop on d6
so this is easy rook takes rook rook
takes rook Bishop H for the Queen moves
somewhere and we win the bishop if Queen
afore we take the rook Bishop takes a
fake Queen takes f8 and black is up a
bishop Queen e5 I forgot about I should
have seen Queen e5 but somehow this is
still good take the rook takes off aids
maybe f6 Ben Feingold says always play
off six right f6 and then the Queen
cannot stay defending both the rook and
the bishop and will take one of them
Wow sneaky but we can just take and then
be up a bishop in the end okay that's
nice
Joker son enjoying my high activity on
YouTube
I actually have not been active too
recently in the last week but I just
uploaded did I publish the video I don't
know if I hit publish and go to my
channel I intended to publish a video
just like actually right before I
started the stream maybe I'll publish it
after this dream no it's published 16
minutes ago I published puzzle rush
video my first uploaded in like a week
or two I think was my previous upload
yeah week ago i'ma try and stay active
it's been difficult there's just so many
things going on a lot to juggle
okay um let's play some people let's go
and play this guy first person to
challenge me hopefully a person and
let's play let's play e4 this is rated
blitz he'll play a Spanish let's play a
Spanish
in honor of some guy named Roy Lopez 9f
six so we have a Berlin I don't know
what to play in separately and I'm gonna
play d3 some sort of anti Berlin Bishop
c5 Castle
I honestly don't know too much theory
here I'm just gonna try and play normal
moves I think I have a threat like when
I'm when I Castle I was threatening to
take on c6
let's play c3 we treat this like a
typical slower Spanish type position
start with 92 bit more positional in
nature I think black is pretty content
with a bishop develop to c5 and this
might end up transposing and into some
Italian but who knows and play h3 very
typical move so I want to play rook e1
but I don't want to allow Knight g4
followed by f5
also putting the question to see what
black is doing Bishop can drop back
drop back even further now I think we've
sort of transposed into Italian my goal
is to do this he's kind of doing the
same thing with his Knights
hey it's bits
was it bits no it's a donation Abdul
Abdul Benz I don't think I've heard that
name before
thanks for the three dollars I was very
generous
who are you it's like one of the most
alphabetically first people that I've
seen in a while
d4 we trade the ship before let's play G
Nigeria
three dollars is a lot of money in
Malaysia I get buys it almost buy is
like a full meal
hmm Bishop III can play b4 like be for a
for let's do it
so thing about this sort of opening like
white can play on both sides of the
board let's play this
I like the tension because black doesn't
really ever want to take always has to
worry about me taking or maybe playing
a5 Bishop d7
I'm gonna play Queen and Queen or above
Bishop to e3
maybe Bishop b3 that's why Bishop b3
more active square because he gave up
control of this diagonal if he plays
Bishop e6 back that would be kind of
funny I would have had a decision to
make but maybe he wants to play a 5 ok
let's play Bishop e3 I'd be happy to get
the double e pawns what am i doing in
Malaysia I'm playing chess and I'm
streaming but now I've it was just sort
of a mini vacation I've only been here
for five days
I'm flying to Australia tomorrow Bishop
d5 is a natural move while them I move
so far have just been purely intuition
based not too much calculation based b9
f5
and five
still relying on intuition assume if he
takes I'll be happy yeah Malaysia has
been really nice I mean would have liked
to stay longer but try to make the most
of my time here I went did like first
time ever I did like this Airbnb
experience yesterday which involves like
traveling through the jungle going like
off trail finding some hidden waterfall
seeing monkeys it's pretty cool
I forgot about night isse Evan I
probably should have calculated before
going into this line so if I play Bishop
e4 there's g5 so maybe I take first I
can take if takes back then Bishop e4
looks a little bit sketchy but I'm
trying weather the storm if Knight takes
d5 pawn takes b6 and we're just trading
takes ticks ticks ticks ticks
not sure who's coming out on top it
still seems relatively balanced I feel
like I should take keep some initiative
b5 might be a target Queen b3 starting
to I some some focal points also
stopping Knight d5 might have ideas of
like rook a7 is beginning to apply some
pressure I might be threatening this too
so going d7 is a normal move let's play
rock a6
because the knight is also a target
Knight doesn't have too many squares I
guess it can move to a4 which I kind of
forgot about and then my rook is kind of
stuck
hmm but if 9a for maybe Queen D 563 66
there's also 9a for c4 which could be
interesting
Queen c7 okay defending the Knights on
defending the pawn I want to play rook
a1 first let's do it
just want to improve my pieces or k7
coming and there's stuff on the seventh
rink that black has to be concerned to
that but everything is defended right
now Knight c5 could be coming so let's
play queen of queen d5
I don't think c3 can be taken because
I've rook see one followed by rook takes
g7 meanwhile I want to capture a d6 d6
is not easy to defend as a queen can't
defend it b6 is off-limits from the rook
so let's run up on maybe now he'll take
on c3 but I still have rook c1 rook c1
Queen b3 I take g7 I'd like to play
Queen e7 here I think it it's okay so
I've sevens of targets and e5 is a
target - I probably could have taken on
e5
now it's too late I could take on f7
play rook c1 first let's take on f7
so black and windy 3 I think the goal
here is just to start attacking like
night h4 Knight g6 possibilities let's
not get the Queen to trapped let's play
this and then this just holding on to d3
and when I'm given the chance I would
like to play Knight h4 night g6 maybe
right away now okay this pawn should not
be too problematic and this is a kind of
attack tonight g6 is coming I'll
probably play rook d1 soon
let's take the rook first
rook t1 take the pawn
I can take the night to it's a nice gift
resigned right as I was about to take
the night's a good game it was
interesting kind of Spanish grind I
think black was okay out of the opening
and then so the thing about the Spanish
like kind of so long fights and things
got messy around here because I miss 97
I had to improvise with B takes e5
things worked out in the end so hello to
more people in the chat let me scroll up
check to the King is that OB chest
jumper
Senor Rosen I don't even know what that
comment means you need to stop
procrastinating did you consider
watching my stream procrastinating
because then you should stop chess
improves memory does it maybe it does
well part of Australia I am I going to
I'm going to Adelaide in Melbourne and
maybe Sydney and maybe Gold Coast I was
looking at flights earlier I'm trying to
figure out like the cheapest way to get
from Australia to Asia around New Year's
and everything is pretty expensive but
there is a there is like some cheap
flight from Gold Coast so I'm still
still figuring things out
joana try is in the chat is there music
there better not be music unless I've
been hacked
okay it's your computer that's good
Joana
I think I was watching your stream
earlier but I just like I fell asleep
like whatever music you had playing it
was so soothing clap says next would
Jenin
thanks for the clap grooving Kurtz hello
Joanna
thanks for the three bits Matthew mob
you're in Sydney if you're in Sydney
have you been to the this restaurant the
queenside
is it just Queen side there's a queen
side something we inside two chests it's
like the one of the only chess themed
restaurants in the world as far as I
know I really want to go there that's
like the main reason why I want to visit
Sydney is because they named a drink
after me
and I want to go to to try it so I'll
try and stop by for a few days oh my
jumper you are wearing right now oh you
call it a jumper okay like I call this a
hoodie or like a jacket I forgot that
jumper is like a form of clothing
stumper you know yes I'm in Malaysia you
live in Malaysia what I'm only here for
a few more hours do you live in in Kuala
Lumpur because I'm that's where I've
been saying for the last like five days
check - the king is sorry you're from
the UK why do you have to be sorry about
that oh because he was using the term
jumper okay that's okay it's good
reminder there's all this like weird
turns
we're like terminology that even amongst
English speakers it can be confusing 40
minutes from Kol yeah it's just like a
mini-vacation kind of a work occasion
but yeah I've been enjoying my time I'm
in Malaysia because it was the easiest
way to get from London to Australia I
basically just picked the kind of the
Midway airports and what what I actually
did initially was I just was searching
for flights from London to Australia and
most of them just had the had one stop
in Malaysia so I used that to my
advantage
yeah okay let's play another game Napa
tune
I'm conflicted also I'm really tired so
I'm not gonna stay along around for too
much longer
who wants to so Niemann kia das says
please accept my challenge but i don't
know who you are
oh that's you well these people have
been waiting longer I'm gonna play this
guy he's been waiting the longest czp
I'm not staying at a hotel
I'm staying at an Airbnb but it feels
like a hotel
really nice has a pool has a gym has a
restaurant okay good luck have fun maybe
I'll play another Spanish yo hablo poca
español hey we'll play an exchange
Spanish in honor of toilet noggin annual
castle now I have to remember what I'm
doing maybe D 3 D 3 is a move
usually the planet is just like d3
Bishop III and Knight bTW - and I'm okay
if black takes on f3 and we'll have just
a solid kind of positional battle 97
okay so not getting double plums
yes it is a question like what to do
next
I'm gonna play a really weird move here
but it's a move that I've seen before
in similar types of positions Queen B 1
the idea is maybe twofold first of all I
get out of the pin so there's no like
annoying that h4 I mean not eh for I
still playable and then I can just take
and then additionally I want to play B
for a 4 B 5 and just attack if black
castles Queen side or maybe just gain
space like B 4 a 4 and see what happens
yeah how do you stream snipe chests
because it's not like poker where like
poker there's hidden information but
just all the information is right in
front of you I guess you could listen in
to my ideas but even if you know what my
ideas are you can't stop them so be for
I don't understand h6 o maybe preventing
Bishop g5 okay that's good sign
my queen might want to activate like
queen bee - or queen bee three let's
play a four
okay so castling kingside it's logical
like queen bee too
connecting the rooks
I'm honestly not sure what I'm gonna do
next just wait to see what he does the
e5 is like an obvious target but it's so
well defended that can't really exploit
it I don't really want to play b5 kind
of fix his black structure so maybe
someday I'll go for like d4 but that
opens up the bishop Queen e7 so he wants
to play a five he's also attacking the
pawn it's nice multi-purpose move
so if I play b5 yeah maybe it's it's
time for b5 fixing block structured but
trying to open up something on the
queenside
maybe b7 will be a target later
at some point I might like to play
Knight c4 or even pawn c4 exploit the
bishop also imagining some lion like see
takes b-58 XB v a5 I could add b6
creating some weakness
mmm time management is good
there is a three-second increment so he
won't flag if he moves quickly enough
but if he gets a long time it's more
likely to have some blunders
if you calculate everything out loud
then I can leech your calculations and
it's like you're playing against
yourself but yeah and maybe that's true
but then you have to like wait until the
stream delay or like wait extra time
because of the stream delay and then
you'll flack
and I don't always like predict my
opponent's moves either that's one thing
I've kind of learned that just try not
to shout out the best moves for the
opponent b6 okay normal middle are
Beasley with $10 sorry Beasley some nice
donations today three dollars $10 a pies
like two decent sized meals in malaysia
and i have a feast of the airport's
pretty soon do I take the rook take the
rook I could play Knight c4 by h3
I'm gonna fight h3
because it actually puts the question to
the bishop
hey it's bits from sarin Elio 500 bits
thanks hearing Elio take the rook no I
don't want to surrender the the a file
may be night c4
applying some pressure I don't see
anything wrong with it
and now I actually have three attackers
on e5 so I didn't realize it when I
played an IED c4 but I might just be
threatening Knight takes e5
so f6 might be expected
or that let's play queen bee to keeping
the attack
mm-hmm
I'm looking for targets in box position
but everything's so well defended
there's no obvious targets I think I'm
gonna play a sneaky move Bishop d2 some
idea of taking and playing Bishop b4
also ideas of 93 the night is just
happier like kind of tucked between the
pawns or than I have ideas of 95 or not
5
all these Spanish games they're a long
fights
it's like these opening battles like go
well into the middle game and it's not
clear like who's better
both of us have chances you might want
to attack not really that's scared of
sacrifices on h3 at least yet I'm more
scared of like Knight f4
so what to do I could take on a then
play rock a one
hmm
play king h2 don't like a lying aligning
my king with the bishop though
maybe Bishop before my bishops doing
nothing and he has a bishop hair so I
would like to trade it off if he plays
he five then it's weakening to be six
and most importantly I'm making him
think he hasn't blundered yes but the
goal is to just keep tension and some
day induce a blunder okay h3 now I'm a
little bit concerned
Aion III keeps things safe but I would
like some more safety
I'm gonna play nine h4 if Sox on the h3
I'll have Knight g2 and then and another
wise I'll have Knight f5 coming I should
probably up the tempo
wait a minute I overlooked something but
I don't think it's that bad unless it's
really bad we'll have to go back and
analyze later g6 is interesting move I'm
gonna play rookie one wait a minute
now I'm gonna play King eh - hmm
such a confusing position
I really don't know what to do let's
play Queen c3 having some x-ray vision
this is the slowest time scramble ever
let's play F for now maybe take then c3
and then later playoff for or maybe play
d4 like we're both under 10 seconds and
we're moving so slowly put the rock on
do you want
rotate to coming
I really want to play this
and this is a threat kind of
control the a file again
mmm free pawn or free nights
finally blundered
this is looking fun
yeah I don't know what to make of that
game I think I was in trouble at some
points and then we both got low on time
it's such a slow time scramble there's a
moment there I was scared when I played
a night h4 I was actually scared of this
and the thing I overlooked is why I
originally played that H why I thought I
could just play Knight g2 and defend
everything but 92 his meat and that
would have been tragic and meanwhile
they I can't defend 90 to end the threat
of Queen takes h4 I don't think so if
this were to happen if Bishop takes h3
I'd probably just start crying and then
I would realize I can't take the bishop
I don't know what I would do
Knight f5 probably because that's what
stockfish recompense
and then maybe later like there are
still ideas if Bishop takes h3 but here
it's a bit fuzzier because g6 is hanging
in some positions like maybe here I
could take on g6 and it gets really
weird Samsonite thanks for a hundred
bits have fun at work doesn't sound so
fun yeah I forgot that like now it was
around the time that people start
heading to work in the u.s. like it's
about rush hour right 7 just after 7:30
a.m.
it's 9:30 6 p.m. I have to wake up early
tomorrow
Chris HD thanks for the sub
yeah I'm in Malaysia because I'm heading
to Australia and I'm leaving tomorrow
pretty soon I think that's gonna be my
last game just because I'm tired do I
ever do speed chess on stream this let's
be chess right I've done bullet too I
mean I do most time controls
wait what's insanely exciting but I'm
going to sleep or I'm going to Australia
I I have been to Brisbane I was in
Brisbane last year for one day because I
I found just the most incredible flight
deal ever from Chicago to Brisbane one
way for $340 with one stop in Shanghai
and it was a great flights China Eastern
Airlines provided meals for breakfast
lunch and dinner on both flights it was
great
Brisbane it was I don't know wasn't the
most exciting compared to like Melbourne
but I was impressed with like how clean
and how friendly everyone was or how
clean the place was and how friendly the
people were so it was good I don't know
if I'll meet on dress if I go to Sydney
I'll try to we'll see
both sound nice yeah at this point sleep
sounds nicer than anything else
okay autumn on being autumn on
okay I think I'm gonna wrap it up thanks
guys for watching hope you guys enjoyed
a couple Spanish games a couple puzzles
maybe I'll upload this to YouTube I have
to start uploading streams to YouTube
again I need to hire someone I need to
hire someone to like just do the upload
stuff and write the write the copy for
the streams at some point I'm gonna have
like application or Google Form or
whatever but for now goodnight or good
morning wherever you are and I'll see
you guys in the future